hey 42 here let me tell you about a
beautiful and very real 19th century
love story involving a spellbound couple
in love a quaint little barn in the
English countryside and the bunch of
body parts sold at auction well I never
said it was a love story with a happy
ending in 1827 at 22 years of age
William quarter of Polster a sleepy
English village and Suffolk plans to
elope to that most classic of elopement
location ISM if switch with Maria Martin
the daughter of a local mole capture
they have planned to meet in the middle
of the night of the local Red Barn so
named because of its red roof and so
Maria met quarter in the red barn that
night and she was never seen alive again
Corder fled poles dead without talking
to anyone I know he didn't even leave a
note saying I've just slaughtered my
girlfriend in that creepy looking barn
the cheek of it Maria's remains were
later discovered buried in a grain
storage bin at the Red Barn so I think
their elopement went really well
Corder evaded capture for some time but
he was eventually tracked down 90 miles
away in Brentford London where he had
managed to find a new wife and he was
running a ladies boardinghouse the
natural career progression for any
aspiring young psychopath after his
capture the local newspapers reported
that he was found quote-unquote in
parlor with four ladies at breakfast in
dressing-gown and had a watch before him
by which he was minuting the boiling of
some eggs I mean let the man finish
boiling his goddamn egg before you slap
the cuffs on him that's just downright
rude but something about this murder and
boiled egg fanatic caught the public's
eye and in a big big way the media all
over Britain were reporting of William
quarters story of elopement betrayal
murder red bombs and eggs
those poor overcooked egg
the public went wild for it they wrote
songs and performed plays of the
infamous Red Barn Murder House it has
come to be known well I guess we all
just needed something to occupy our days
with before Joe McHale brought a daily
dose of inbreeding and social
disfigurement into our homes now when I
say that the public went wild for this
unfortunate tale I mean to say that they
behaved like a pack of wild priests at a
boarding school the Red Barn itself was
raided and completely emptied by the
public in search of souvenirs from the
crime scene even the wooden panels from
the floorboards and walls were priced
off in souls you can just imagine it now
murder planks get your murder planks
only a shilling apiece to blood still
warm folks a novel was published about
the case which quickly became a
best-seller
Corda was hanged and immediately
afterwards bits of the Rope used to hang
him was sold to the public and most
gruesome of all the body parts were
chopped up and auctioned to the highest
bidders not for medical purposes nope
just disturbing souvenirs quarters skin
was even used to bind a book as can be
seen here some say afterwards the book
grew hair all throughout the 18th and
19th centuries plays were frequently
performed detailing the Red Barn murder
why am I crazy for thinking that that's
rather crazy why did the public get so
deeply in fraud with this case overnight
William Cora had been raised to
celebrity or rock star status yet Korda
was by all accounts a manipulative lying
cheating abusive Megillah manic
psychopath who enjoyed chopping up women
and hiding them inside piles of grain in
fact his only redeeming feature was that
he cared deeply about the dullness of a
boiled egg in a perfect society should
we not forget about such an evil
character confining them to the annals
of history and not give the case so much
attention thereby only glorifying the
horrible act that the killer
formed yet we do quite the opposite we
all do we are all obsessed with the
sinister and the macabre
oh stop trying to deny it you're worse
than all the others I'm just as guilty
as the next man of cracking open a beer
and enjoying a Netflix documentary about
the next serial killer who may or may
not be guilty why are novels films and
TV shows about killers so much more
popular than the average rom-com even in
a world where romantic filmmakers could
actually write I still believe this
would hold true face it the sick general
public absolutely loves a good gruesome
murder story and the more kills the
perpetrator has to their name the more
we lap it up like a sadistic mentally
ill kitten and this has been the case
for as long as man with long beard and
stubby nose hit man with beady eyes over
the head with big rock spilling red goo
that man can't drink all over the cave
floor less than 150 years ago Jack the
Ripper murdered and disemboweled
anywhere from five to eleven prostitutes
in Whitechapel London yet today he's as
much of a household name as Jesus or
silat banging there are many
Jack the Ripper fan clubs out there
hundreds of books plays songs TV shows
and films all because a crazy man down a
back alley
once sliced open some women to see what
was inside the ironic thing is Jack the
Ripper knew how sick the general public
were and how famous he would inevitably
become because he branded himself in a
letter that may have been written by the
man himself he administered himself the
moniker of Jack the Ripper
I would have gone for slicey Piet myself
but I guess it's a matter of personal
preference the stories of these
professional psychopaths are endless
such as dr. Harold Shipman nicknamed dr.
death the doctor who murdered over 250
of his own patients h/h Holmes the
American serial killer who designed and
constructed a purpose-built hotel in
hidden rooms and passageways in the
walls for the sole purpose of torturing
and murdering his victims of which there
were an estimated 200 Lewis gaffer Ito
nicknamed the Beast
a Colombian rapists and serial killer
who sexually abused tortured and killed
over a hundred and thirty-eight children
and those are just the tip of a very
large and deeply evil iceberg the
Yorkshire Ripper Ian Brady and Myra
Hindley Ted Bundy Gavin Ridgeway I could
go on and on all day in fact the United
States has produced 2743 serial killers
to date and the UK is hot on its heels
with 145 psycho murderers on its list
but have you ever noticed how we glorify
these monsters by giving them cool
sounding nicknames like Jack the Ripper
dr. death the Beast
the Grim Sleeper Son of Sam the Green
River Killer the lady killer
BTK it's like Quentin Tarantino and Wes
Anderson had a love child and it made a
film about serial killers you can just
picture the beautifully pastel colored
introductory title cards but don't you
think it's a bit strange how we are
quicker to give an awesome sounding
moniker to mass murdering psychopath
stunts who our favorite sports players
for example it's almost like the moment
someone disposes of a few people they
automatically have a god-given right to
a cool nickname and the general public
lap it up Swiss psychiatrist Carl Jung
believes it's because we all need to
feed our shadow self our shadow self is
our dark side that part of you that
secretly wants to punch some nun in the
face even though you know it's wrong
very wrong we all have it and
psychiatrists believe that by watching
serial killers on TV carrying out
heinous acts and learning how they
performed said acts we are scratching
that itch Doug we all have to explore
our dark side or from the safe comfort
of
couch research shows that we find
indulging our dark side from afar
therapeutic Greek philosopher Aristotle
was curious why his fellow humans were
obsessed with plays about horrific
things like murder and incest everyone
just loves a good tragedy
Aristotle concluded that by experiencing
what he called dark emotions such as
disgust fear and depravity we can
cleanse ourselves of such emotions he
calls this process catharsis so
according to Aristotle the next time
you're lying in bed next to your wife
and that fort just pops into your head
again go on go on
just put the pillow over her face it
will only take a minute
and I'll be free you should instead pop
on a gory horror film or a true crime
documentary and experience some good old
catharsis to cleanse that evil little
person from your mind and if that
doesn't work for you that I'm afraid
you're just going to have to start
planning where to hide the body another
reason why we find serial killers
absolutely fascinating is because of how
perplexing difficult and alien the
concept of committing and getting away
with multiple murders is to us I've
never tried it myself but I can imagine
it really really difficult to murder
someone and not get caught after all the
majority of murders are solved
approximately 2/3 of killers are
eventually caught in today's world of
advanced forensic ballistics criminal
psychology CCTV everywhere and internet
and phone tracking no matter how smart
you think you are only one tiny mistake
needs to be made before you're found out
and cuffs have been slapped onto your
wrists faster than you can say the
voices made me do it
so naturally we find someone who can
avoid being caught for many years whilst
committing more than one murder
sometimes many many murders absolutely
fascinating after all that takes some
skill you have to admit
on some level we find it impressive in
the same way we find highly-skilled
acrobatic skydivers doing twists and
turns whilst plummeting terminal
velocity towards a 6,000 kilometer rock
quite impressive we feel exhilarated
watching these skydivers because it's a
terrifying experience that most of us
would never dream of actually doing yet
we all secretly want to know how it
would feel so we can live that
experience through watching and learning
about someone else doing it on our
behalf in this regard our fascination
with serial killers is absolutely no
different
maybe this psychology also explains why
so many people watch horrendously trashy
TV shows like Keeping Up with the
Kardashians and honey boo boo just so we
can experience free offers what it would
feel like to be that stupid there's
another deep-rooted evolutionary
psychological reason for our love of
serial killers uncertainty humans hate
the unknown we always have the same fear
of the unknown can be seen in other
intelligent creatures it's why apes at
the zero way seem so curious of new
objects they're only interested because
they're trying to discover if this new
unknown object will hurt them or not and
so too are humans afraid of what may be
around the corner what is beyond the
forest or across the oceans during our
200,000 year span as modern Homo sapiens
we have found a way to deal with our
flavor of the unknown we dominate it we
can't predict what a wild animal will do
when we meet it its actions are unknown
to us so we invented weapons to kill
them instead we were afraid of what
dangers may lie across the oceans so we
invented boats and we took our weapons
and we dominated the oceans and
everything beyond them and then the
British did the exact same thing with
the addition of many many flax
simply because on a deeply psychological
level it terrified us not knowing what
may be out there it has been suggested
by many a psychologist that serial
killers kill for the exact same reason
because they are afraid so they feel a
need to dominate their environment many
people who suffer from psychopathy have
trouble speaking to and becoming
romantically entangled with women so
they instead choose to dominate them
through rape and murder it's no
coincidence that an overwhelming amount
of serial killers throughout history
have chosen prostitutes as their victims
some may have been beaten and abused as
a child so they fear what other humans
may do to them thus they decide to
dominate them instead serial killers
often practice this domination on
animals before they do on humans just as
the human race first practiced
dominating cattle and sheep before using
the exact same technique to enslave
humans during times of war and famine as
observers we find people dominating
covers absolutely fascinating because it
teaches us how to conquer the unknown we
learn what we might do if we were put
into the exact same situation of either
the killer or the victim it's the same
McCobb reason why horrific car crash
videos online are so popular and fail
videos where people have horrendous
bones shuttering accidents even if
sometimes they did have it coming we
aren't all psychopaths and although it
may make us feel guilty watching these
videos all we are really doing is
feeding a primal urge to dominate the
unknown deep down we just want to answer
a simple question what if what would
happen if I was in that situation and by
studying serial killers and enjoying
true crime documentaries we find out
what happens if we were to go on a
satanic killing spree and hopefully by
watching a story of these killers unfold
before us it can dissuade us from
following a sim
path because others are already
conquering the unknown for us whilst we
stuff our faces with popcorn so then I
guess thank you
serial killers you are providing a vital
service for all of humanity no wait I
can't say that I can't actually thank
them they're our victims after all okay
how about this
serial killers you are very very naughty
but from your naughtiness may we all
learn to be better people there you go
that's better
I think thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please click
here to support me on patreon which
really helps out the channel click here
to watch another video and if you
haven't already don't forget to
subscribe